what
what do you think is the most legitimate
verifiable
evidence that we have of aliens like i
know there's all these crazy things
people find and you know you can find
this
hieroglyphic of a of a hydrogen bomb you
know
or see all these things and you can make
all these these assumptions about it
or all these connections to it but what
do you think is like the most
concrete evidence of this stuff or the
most concrete like encounter or sighting
or whatever it is
well well here's the thing no matter you
know it's funny if you talk about
certain events people well if i could
just see what bigfoot looks like
and then you get a picture like well
that's not that's not really him that's
not oh no
i think you're going to have a problem i
think even if tomorrow if aliens landed
and we're shaking everybody's hand and
going okay we're here there'll still be
people going nah that's not real
that's not real that's all that's so i
don't think there's any one event i
think it's more
when eric von danigan came out and
started saying what he was saying the
scientific community
was looking at him like with
pseudoscience you're an idiot
but for whatever reason the rest of the
planet
started to get it they started to see
the same things
that he was seeing i mean you know
does god really fly around on a carpet
somebody was flying around on a carpet
they wouldn't have said aladdin i mean
yeah so these things that are flying and
there's wars
going on these things that are happening
have to be looked at more than just like
well it was just somebody's great
imagination well
no that's that's not that's that's your
opinion
but when you look at each of the
cultures that are out there they all
seem to have
something unique about what they do but
it's also shared so again
when you start looking at the stars and
we start talking about astrology we
started talking about
different times of the year they all
seem to have this same thing in common
but they all couldn't be so good with
the stars and planets
i mean i don't know if you guys have
ever tried to track like venus but it's
crazy because it moves so fast across
the sky even in the summertime when we
go from summer time to winter time the
sun moves real quick
and so it moves actually the sun moves
farther
north and it does it like in a couple of
weeks because
as the earth starts to rotate around but
how would you know that
back then i mean where do these people
get their knowledge to even ask that
question
yeah what what do they say about for
them to actually
for uh the egyptians or the mines or
whoever it was that
were able to account for the the equal
is it
what's called the wobble it's called the
equinox the equinox of the wobble
correct
i i can't remember exactly but it was
like you would need to take measurements
for like over a hundred years or
something like that to be able to
account for the wobble of the earth to
pick up it was more than that i was like
maybe like maybe like
500 years or something it could have
been yeah it could have been some crazy
number because again now the wobble
happens
yearly that's what gives us our seasons
you know as it kind of you know if the
plane is like this and it kind of rocks
this way
north now has become farther down and
you start to work yourself up
and it becomes a whole different yeah
it's the equinox the equinox
i mean you can really tell by the way
the light changes too when it starts to
shift because the way the light hits in
the summer it definitely hits different
than it is oh yeah for sure i mean my
grass
i can see it at the yard i've actually
got some points marked like where the
first day of winter is where the first
day of summer is
you can track it by the shadows and
that's exactly and i put rocks by it
because it's my own little thing that
i've done there but
um so going back and look at what
they've done you're like okay
i get that but you know of course the
question comes out where do these
cultures go where did the egyptians go
where did the mayans go you know all
those
they got they got mixed up with the
spanish and the spanish had diseases and
they died because
that's just too convenient mike was
there time to convenience was there
a time in your life before
like was there a time or like some sort
of
event that happened where you just
started paying attention to the sky
or was a time you just never because i
can remember
a time like up until recently i never
pay attention
or look at the sky ever during the day
sure like i like who
how many people actually take
a couple minutes of the day to pay
attention to what's going on they don't
you're too busy on your phone you're
driving
you're looking at your laptop you're
doing work on your whatever you're doing
talking to somebody like very very i bet
you less than one percent of people on
on the planet spend more than five
minutes a day looking at
paying attention to what's going on in
the sky sure unless you see an airplane
or a helicopter something that like
catches your attention
you gotta slow down and let the light in
man yeah
look up well i think too that some
people you're either
what i've noticed with some people is
that they're more aware of things than
than others
and it's almost a natural thing um you
know again
kind of for instance i'm with a bunch of
guys we're traveling we're doing a big
backpack trip through the mountains
i happen to see a deer with a fawn
and they're they're kind of jumping
around and she's playing with this
little thing and i
i didn't get a chance to stop and see
the other guys yet so they could even
see it so as i turned around to talk to
him
two of the other guys where the group
had seen the same thing but the other
four were completely oblivious to it
so some people just have that natural
ability i think to be
more interested in what's going on um
you know stargazing so stargazing starts
out of stargazing and also when you see
something like
what is that why is it doing that
so that's where i mean for me as a boy
scout
that's what kind of started for me right
we're out camping one night
we're all kind of having a fun time and
we see a what look like a meteorite and
it probably was
yeah you know but i was like wow dude i
can't i could see that with my eyes you
know being a young guy you don't realize
that
and so you start looking at additional
things and even our last podcast we
talked about
i want to say it was 94. um i'm coming
back from
tampa it's four o'clock in the afternoon
and there's this great big gray football
shaped thing at the top of that tower
right since that picture of where
the building was next to it you talked
about that in the last podcast
and there was other people coming in the
comments saying they saw the same thing
really yes see so dude when i saw that
that time i'm like
dude it's four o'clock in the afternoon
rush hour traffic and i'm looking at
this thing like
nobody else is seeing that so i'm
thinking well okay it's a blimp
and it got off and it's got caught at
the top of the tower yeah yeah the weird
thing was
that the the line there was a line that
went from the from this
whatever it was to the top of the tower
but it had it was there was
slack in it it wasn't pulled tight so i
know this is a 500 foot tower i know
that 500 feet above the ground
that wind is whipping pretty good so
that thing would have been moving but it
didn't move at all
and i really i mean you're so like well
if nobody else is paying attention to it
it can't be really anything
right but i couldn't get that thing off
of my mind
and so at the time there was nothing
there to
say wow it was as big as that building
they built this 10 story building
almost right next to the tower when
you're coming across franklin bridge so
you can see it
and i'm i'm like it was as big as that
building it literally was as big as that
building and so
i uh probably eight or nine months after
the fact
i actually went to this facility it's
still there there's a huge fence around
it
you can't get into the building you're
not going to walk into it you have to
there's a security
so when i i rang the buzzer and the
guy's like hey all deliveries go around
back i'm like listen
i'm going to have a delivery i got a
question for you though he's like yeah
what is it
and i said hey about nine months ago i
saw something at the top of your tower
that was either caught on the tower and
i was trying to confirm it was there and
and the first thing he said to me is sir
i want you to get off the property
excuse me i'm just asking get away and
so
he said you said get away from the fence
yeah and then he wouldn't talk to me
anymore there was no more question
coming up
yeah so you know again was that real
it was something if people chimed in so
they must have seen it also well that's
what i'm saying you can get away with so
much
[ __ ] in the air because no one's paying
attention
nobody's staring at the sky four o'clock
in the afternoon
not a thing not a thing it doesn't have
to be that high it could probably just
be like 10 feet in the air people
wouldn't see it dude like i said this
was fun
this was 500 feet this wasn't like you
know like you're even
i watched the uh the the um uh
space shuttle flew by here the other
night pretty cool
i was in a great location watched the
whole thing go by if you didn't know it
was a space shuttle you
thought was a plane there was no
flashing lights it was just a straight
line but it was a
bright color light and this thing is
moving at 25 000 miles an hour
but it looked like a plane that was
maybe moving to four or 500 miles an
hour
is that how fast the rockets go 25 so
well the the space shuttle knows the
space shuttle
that's why when they have like a part
all this space debris up there floating
around
that it's moving also at 25 it'll punch
a hole oh yeah
right through the side of this thing so
they're always constantly looking at
space junk and trying to figure out
but again watching this thing go through
the air i mean you wouldn't if you
didn't know it was coming through that
night you just thought it was a plane
i know that people said what are you
doing i'm watching the space shuttle
flavor
i sure are whatever go yeah go enjoy
your beer
yeah where were you at i was over in
tampa i was doing some
uh i had a lady over there i was working
for and um
it was you know ten o'clock nights in a
great area it's a it's in a very very
well to do neighborhood
it's at the end of the road right over
the bay um i've got a perfect view i can
see everywhere i can see over to mcdill
and i can see over down to the
howard franklin nice i'm right at the
point matter of fact there's no houses
there
that lot that's at the end of this piece
of probably going for 10 million
so just to give you an idea of the kind
of the area that i'm in yeah but
nice and dark i mean i can see
everything out there and just a really
really cool event it's super cool
to watch it you watched it with like uh
binoculars just
straight just your eyes man just your
eyes didn't have any problem watching it
whatsoever
that's cool so those little type of
events you know start to happen and then
you know my son had a couple things
happen he's like dude i just saw
something so weird tonight
you know and this is in our neighborhood
now if you look at
this area we live in here yeah that's my
i have a problem with this area because
there's not enough ufos in this area
if you look at the map aiden if you can
find the map of ufo sightings in the
united states in the past 10 years
it shows you all of the reports people
report ufo sightings every
absolutely absolutely and this is like
one of the dead zones
the west coast of florida you think
there might be more activity with the
military base because
aren't they usually well it's funny you
said that because i i actually watched
they were doing special operations will
run
certain uh vehicles at certain times of
the year so these ospreys they have that
the marines use for special operations
they were flying them around one one
weekend and i knew that's what they were
so i kind of went outside to go watch
them
and this is what i sent to moof on as
i'm watching this
and i had my phone out and i'm kind of
zeroing in on this one osprey and i
you know it's probably 25 or 30 miles
away
and i wasn't trying to videotape this
but something shoots out of the side
i like to have the aliens zoom out that
works crucial
see look at that man florida's looking a
little hot
zooming up zoom in on florida actually
we're just looking hot
i thought they were all over on like
we're looking real hot right now holy
[ __ ] those are all you mike
mike mike dude there's something in the
air every single night actually this
area i'm way off i thought what i saw
there was like none in this area
all the ones that i saw in florida were
like centered around the cocoa beach
area this one's definitely legit
well listen to a picture of it people
are more aware today you know so
they're kind of they're a lot more apt
to report something today than they were
10 years ago
everybody has a phone now so they can
pull it out and record that event as
well whatever it is
oh look the northeast is real hot i mean
so yeah could all those people be wrong